bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo pasado
no sé que estaba pensando de hecho creo
que mi cerebro no estaba funcionando muy
bien que digamos pero voy a retomar el
ejercicio anterior hay días que amanezca
un poco esquizofrénico pero pero vamos a
retomar el ejercicio anterior el
ejercicio anterior si lo podemos
terminar y vamos a hacerlo yo tenía una
circunferencia y quería sacar el volumen
de una esfera de circunferencia era de
la forma x cuadrada más y cuadrada igual
a un radio al cuadrado y qué pasa si yo
despejó ayer pues tengo que ya cuadradas
igual a r cuadrada menos ex cuadrada o
dicho de otra manera y es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de r cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada bien intentemos dibujar lo voy
a dibujar el eje de las 10 el eje de las
x y voy a utilizar la herramienta de de
los círculos perdón otra vez está
siguiendo el truco pero ahora sí ya
quedó ok utilicemos la mente de los
círculos y voy a hacer este dibujo así
que quede bien esta circunferencia
esta circunstancia va a quedar aquí aquí
un poquito más grande perfecto pero no
no no algo mal de hecho está esta
gráfica solamente es la parte superior
de esta circunferencia entonces voy a
borrar esta circunferencia y voy a
intentar dibujar este pues a mano mi
parte superior de mi circunferencia es
solamente la parte superior si quisiera
la parte inferior de mi circunferencia
pues tendría que tener menos la raíz
cuadrada de re cuadrada menos ex
cuadrada os voy a dibujar la mano ahí va
ahí se ve la mitad verdad no se ve
completo no no no esto no me gusta voy a
borrar lo voy a intentar borrarlo perdón
perdón por ocupar su tiempo así de esta
manera pero pero yo creo que va a ser
muy provechoso ocupar esta está este
tiempo en ver este vídeo bien voy a
repetir otra vez el dibujo y empezamos a
nuevo voy a hacer la gráfica de mi
función de igual a la raíz de r cuadrada
- x cuadrada entonces es solamente la
parte superior de mi circunferencia si
quisiera la parte inferior tendría que
tener la red
- raíz de ere cuadrada menos equis
cuadrado entonces voy a dibujar la parte
superior de mi circunferencia y aquí va
exacto aquí está y este punto es el
punto menos r y este punto del punto r
bien voy a utilizar otra vez la función
de los de los rectángulos y voy a
dibujar un rectángulo y lo vamos a girar
alrededor del eje de las x esta función
la voy a hacer girar alrededor del eje
de las equis y entonces retomemos la
idea de los discos y de los rectángulos
entonces voy a suponer más bien voy a
hacerlo gráficamente voy a decir que
éste es
la cara superior de mi disco y pues
ahora voy a dibujar el ancho de mi disco
con el mismo color para que sea un disco
de color azul este va a ser el ancho de
mi disco y espero que ustedes al menos
desde una noción de que esto es un disco
y como en los vídeos pasados habrá que
sacar el área de este disco el área de
este disco tiene que ver con el con el
radio este disco lo voy a voy a colorear
el área y vamos a sacar la algebraica
mente el área es igualdad y por radio el
cuadrado porque es un círculo bien
entonces voy a sustituir al radio pero
el radio era igual
fx que es la raíz cuadrada de ere
cuadrada - x cuadrada así está definida
mi función entonces pues el radio es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de ere cuadrada
menos ex cuadrada bien ya con esto podré
sacar del área el área es igual a pi por
el radio al cuadrado pero pues la raíz
con el cuadrado se van si yo tengo la
raíz de ere cuadrada menos equis
cuadrado al cuadrado pues no es
necesario poner la raíz ni el cuadrado
entonces el área es para que multiplica
a r
bien y yo recordaba que el ancho de este
disco pues era tx entonces apoyos a que
el volumen el volumen de espn por radio
el cuadrado por equis cuadrada todo esto
multiplicado por de x
bien y como todos los vídeos pasados lo
que hacíamos era sumar todos los discos
de esta función
sumamos cada uno de los discos que nos
salían al rotar esta función alrededor
del eje las equis y por esto obteníamos
la integral la integral está esta vez
definida entre menos r&r de quien pues
el volumen de cada uno de estos discos o
sea people r cuadrada ya voy a
distribuir de una vez a pi por cada uno
de mis sumandos de adentro es paper
cuadrada que es una constante ya esto le
restamos y por equis cuadrada y todo
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por de x por
la diferencial de x
yo creo que quiero buscar es una
primitiva de esta de esta función
entonces vamos a buscar una primitiva de
pie a re cuadrada la primitiva de piedra
cuadrada ahora sí recuerdo integrales
ahora si me acuerdo de ellas este es el
volumen y entonces la primitiva va a ser
por ere cuadrada por x están de acuerdo
porque es una constante entonces me va a
quedar piporé re cuadrada por equis
ya esto hay que restarle pues la
primitiva de pi por equis cuadrada pero
pues pies una constante y la primitiva
de x cuadrada es x cúbica entre 3
entonces voy a obtener que esto es pin
que multiplica a x cúbica entre 3 y esto
evaluado entre r y menos ser bien ya no
tengo nada de espacio y para seguir con
esto pues voy a borrar algo para poder
obtener espacio espero que ustedes ya se
hayan aprendido esto y se acuerden de
esto y de dónde salió el x cuadrada más
cuadrada igual a earl cuadrada es hora
de sustituir entonces vamos a sustituir
primero en r que obtengo pues el primero
tengo pin por rr cuadrado entonces esto
lo voy a notar igualito pi por r al
cuadrado y esto pues tengo que evaluar
en negro entonces tengo que multiplicar
por r
y esto lo tengo que restar y por el
alcohol porque es x al cubo evaluado en
r me queda r kubica y esto dividido
entre 3 - porque siempre es menos cuando
evaluamos los límites le tengo que
restar pi por ere cuadrada yo la voy a
evaluar en menos r entonces en lugar de
x voy a poner menos
r entonces hacer por por menos r
muy bien y ahora voy a poner en lugar de
x cúbica a menos r pero pues menos r al
cubo es menos r kubica y entonces voy a
poner aquí r cúbica y me falta un menos
lo voy a multiplicar aquí menos por
menos más y dividido entre 3 bien ahora
voy a multiplicar lo que tenga que
multiplicar y por rr cuadrada por r pues
va a ser pi por república entonces voy a
notar y por r kubica y menos tipo de
real entre 3 o sea menos un tercio de pi
por ere al cubo y ahora que me queda de
la otra expresión me queda menos por
menos pues va a ser más entonces una vez
lo eliminó menos por menos va a ser más
y por ere cuadrada por r va a ser y por
qué república me va a quedar más y por
ere elevado al cubo y ya esto lo tengo
que sumar no restar toque menos por más
es menos entonces le voy a tener que
restar menos un tercio de people
repubblica
ya lo tengo hasta aquí y ahora voy a
factorizar el poder al cubo todo tiene
que ver cumplir por el real jugó
entonces voy a factorizar el pi por r al
cubo pi para el cubo que multiplica a
quién
bueno pues primero tengo que perder el
cubo entonces va a ser uno menos un
tercio más uno menos un tercio se ha
vuelto un problema de fracciones porque
uno menos un tercio más uno menos un
tercio pues es lo mismo que dos menos
dos tercios y esto es una resta de
fracciones estos son seis tercios esto
debe quedar seis menos dos entre tres o
dicho de otra manera cuatro tercios todo
esto de aquí son cuatro tercios por lo
tanto ya tengo el volumen de mi esfera y
el volumen de espera va a ser igual a
cuatro tercios de pi por ere al cubo y
esta es la fórmula que nos ha enseñado
siempre en la primaria lo logramos se
dan cuenta y además lo logramos en ocho
minutos y medio yo me siento más feliz
fue un logro muy importante para mí el
hacer este vídeo que yo creía que me va
a salir y espero que ustedes también
estén muy felices de hecho que una
relación
en cuatro tercios pues se relaciona con
todo lo demás pero se relaciona con el
conocimiento que ya sabíamos que es el
área de un círculo el área de un círculo
espín por radio al cuadrado por aquí hay
algo que tiene que ver el uno con el
otro
piénsenlo bueno espero que les haya
agradado este vídeo nos vemos en el
siguiente